[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're idiots what are we doing we're
gonna review a videogame yeah we've done
that a million times why are we dressed
like this I look like someone who was
asked to leave an avant-garde Swedish
pop group why am I wearing Microsoft's
version of the Apple watch today one of
the biggest games of the year this is a
big deal here we go okay and this is
gonna start in the bathroom okay it says
sex on one of them what's that this is
we're gonna create our characters oh I
thought we got the hab set no so we can
change our character here so we can you
can add blemishes oh yeah add blemishes
I love that face no you love that face
cancel that I want my character to have
a chance at getting some action in the
post apocalypse great so now we're in
the game here what is that that's a
robot Butler codsworth and there's a jet
engine coming out his ass he's he's
single-handedly raising the temperature
in the house by 600 degrees and why are
you using a stove codsworth why don't
you just cook it with your ass oh look I
think sex is gonna happen look at her
eyes
you can ask sundar you think what did
she say
codsworth needs to be serviced no I
think someone else needs to be serviced
dude I'll be there in a minute
it's is it on no I think we need to go
change our baby oh right there's a brand
new baby so there's no sex ever again
so now we're gonna jump to 200 years in
the future okay
we've also made the character now look
like you oh is that me yeah that's you
so yeah you can you let's get a look at
me ass is right nice and toned I'm
checking out my own ass right now so we
can go down now and just go and yeah
just oh that's so why jumps there if you
want to jump oh no oh no everywhere in
real life just started the game so in
this game we can get companions so do we
want to have the dog as our companion
yes all right everyone a dog and this is
great we could give them commands he'll
attack bad guys for us so let's kill
something yeah thank you
all right there's gonna be a cool system
times gonna slow down it's called vats
vault-tec assisted targeting system
slow down you machine yes dining machine
all right now hit the trigger oh yeah
yeah and then we're gonna switch the
laser musket using her how do you know
how to do all these quick button things
and oh right you've never been outside
this yeah alright now you now you'll see
our systems change so you were in the
power see we don't need the pip-boy more
in the price let's go forward and
nothing can hurt me now yeah very little
blood bag oh no what
why it's a deathclaw tune adjust the
trigger break where is he I don't know
he's fine oh god you're on fire didn't
say there was a thing
out of the ground that can kill I didn't
know what's gonna happen we died in
these suits the most embarrassing way to
die
maybe your set of posa boxes okay cool
let's see my set yeah wow that's all
powered by generators here's machine
guns yeah we have those actually at the
show sometimes the crowd gets unruly
there's the desk and there's my famous
bison heads that I always keep in the
background also you know we can switch
to the power of this yeah ah what's this
yes look at how must here in my ass is
incredible ass in this reality have you
ever said zombies come into every game
now you could be playing pacman and
zombies will show up now Oh
again accentuating my powerful ass I
think we need a better weapon hold on
tactical boosted agitated plasma pistol
that's what I want
everyday by the time you pronounce it
they've all died of old age take that
feral ghoul oh that gun turns them into
a minty toothpaste gel do you think
there's a chance I could meet a woman in
this world because I have a killer ass
well you you want to be a woman let's go
to Diamond City yeah let's go okay yeah
yeah oh hello hello yeah she just
recognized me look at that she just
recognized that's Conan O'Brien wait she
recognized me she walked away
can you turn around so she can see my
ass run around so she can see my ass
isn't she looking at it the guys
noticing it with the back look he's
checking me out it's not what I wanted
what about her get her walk in front of
her let her see my bottom
[Laughter]
that's great I guess guys cleaning up
look
he's cleaning up good job there in nine
million years you should have this place
spick-and-span one of the groups in the
post-apocalyptic wasteland is the
Brotherhood of Steel I'm paladin dance
Brotherhood of Steel Oh God there
my story is long quite complicated and
boring I will keep talking and telling
you my story it'll be filled with
information I've been trying and only
someone who plays the game a lot would
really want hello you didn't say there
were sisters in the Brotherhood I don't
even know what the mission is I got lost
we're going here to arcjet systems what
two destroyed robots oh that's a bad
sign these robots were assaulted by
Institute since sin isn't that the same
as robot darin of abuse
you could also hack computers boring I
don't wanna hack a computer
well we Ori we we have to at this point
we have to hack this compute why this is
all they do these dishes you've gotta
get on a computer you've got to pay your
bills online we've never let you look at
the heavy doing right now so they have
you on a 1981 Commodore computer paying
your rent this is ridiculous
so we have to choose a word okay so the
tool let's say maybe the O is the one in
the right position how do you hate this
you hate this this is the angriest I've
ever been look at look at all these good
let's get kill everything go go kill oh
you guys made me go on a computer
oK we've played a lot of this game it's
pretty amazing fallout 4 comes out
tomorrow and it's available where
PlayStation 4 Xbox one and PC it is
really fun incredible action incredible
detail love all the weapons love that
VAT system where you can slow down the
bunch don't love all the tasks I gotta
say I hated it when you made me get on a
computer so for that you deserve one of
these babies right here
[Applause]
[Music]
you